abone ol
bu
kıracağım komut bekliyordum bence Evet
burada kendimi görme şansınız olur mu En
azından birilerini görme şansım var mı
yalnız kendimi sahne insan olduğum için
ne yapabiliriz Hah tamam aşkım İyi
akşamlar arkadaşlar Herkese merhaba Az
önce Aslında Türkiye finali izlediniz
Keşke Avrupa finalinde temizleyip sizde
ikinci değil aslında on oldu mm
senesinde ülkemize o kavga etmiştik
boncukta fena bir asla sıralama değildi
Ama o zamana kadarki en iyi ikinci
dereceydi alınan Türkiye'de provizyon
şarkı yarışması benim hayatımda Tabii ki
çok büyük bir değere sahip defa
müzisyenim sanat icra eden bir insanım
aynı zamanda Hacettepe Üniversitesi
İngiliz edebiyatı
Üniversitesi Tıp Fakültesi Halkla
İlişkiler master derslerini almış bir
yandan Efendi okumayı çok seven bir
insanın tarih öğrenmeyi okumayı çok
seven bir insanım ama öte yandan da
gerçekten iki yaşından tam zamana kadar
da şarkı söyleyen insan
sizin programınızın temasının Eko yani
Yankı olması beni çok heyecanlandırdı
birçok açıdan neden mesela Özcan şarkı
yarışmasına aday olarak şarkımız
gönderdiğimizde ruhumuz bizim Yankı ve
oğlumdaki şarkı göndermiştim oğlum
kazanmıştı ama diğeri de Yankı yoğumuzu
Biz yankılanmak için aslında sesimizi
sadece ülkemizde değil dünyada duyurmak
için bir çabalıyordu her zaman atılan
her adıma bir sonrası belki 5-10 sonrası
vardır ye çalıştık hep böyle hareket
ettik dolayısıyla da kendimize sadece
kendi çapında şarkı söyleyen gruplarıyla
şarkı söyleyen dünyaya sesini duyuyorum
Ne haber olarak gördük gidecek böyle
koydum Öyle de oldu ve Yakalandık
yorgunum abla alanla adlı şarkıyı ve
gibisiniz ve öyle bir şarkı yarışmasında
başarı ile temsil neden başarıyla diyor
başarı göreceli kavram 10. olmak çok
başarmak değil belki ama bizim asıl
başarımız şuydu Arkadaşlar bir hafta
sürer orada çalışmalar Romalılar
kaynaşma önemlidir ısınma günlerdi o
günler bir haftanın sonunda zaten
finalde yarışma olur o biraz da boyunca
sizin Diğer ülkelerdeki yarışmacı
dostlarımızla nasıl ilişki kurduğunuz
geldiğinizi nasıl tanıttığınız nasıl bir
Diplomasi yürüttüğünüz Bu yeteneğiniz
nasıl ortaya koyduğumuz çok çok
önemlidir basın toplantısı yapılır her
provadan sonra Bizim basın
toplantısından sonra şunu söylemişti
gazeteciler arkamızdan Türkiye'den
inanılmaz sempatik bir ekip gelmiş o
birkaç yabancı dil konuşabiliyor bir
dertlerini anlatıyorlar çok sıcaklar
hiçbir kompleksleri yok E dost çok güzel
dostluklar duruyorlar gerçekten
başarılar diye arkamızdan konuşmuşlar
bana göre bu da çok pozitif çok anlamlı
olumlu yan kıydık bunu kıymetini de hep
Birlik bizde Tabii aldığımız eğitim
aldığımız ailelerimizden gördüğünüz edep
adap eğitim Az önce Mesut alpatlı çok
güzel bilgiler verdi biz de işte
ailelerimizden o bir ilerleyiş neydi
gider biliyor musunuz kadın ve erkek
eşittir hatta hatta her cins ışıktır
sadece insan değil doğanın bir
parçasıyız de eşit Bu anlamda ne bir
piramit vardır ne üçgen vardır Herkes
bir Dairenin içinde eşit Hatta 12 Daire
dahi yoktur Herkes her yerdedir ve
gücünün yettiği kadar Efendim emeğinin
o kadar birey hizmet eder valla
hizmetleri işte Bizler de bu sevgi
anlayışı ile bu ses saygı anlayışı ile
geçmiş gençler bir Ülkemizi temsil etmek
gittiğimizde belki de o yüzden
yüzümüzden de
sevgimizden de saygı fışkırıyordu
hissettirdi Demek ki diğer ülke
dostlarımıza sonrasında sanıyorum beni
bu konuşmaya davet eden sevgili Güneş ve
Arkadaşları sahnede anlattığı hikayeler
için biraz da sizinle beni tanıştırmak
istediler yıllarca televizyon
programları ısındıktan sonra ki
biliyorsunuz yankılanmasının iz
bırakmanın ses ulaştırmanın en önemli
yollarından biri de Medya yirmi küsür
sene televizyonda Türkiye Radyo
Televizyon Kurumu da sunuculuk yaptım e
pek çok farklı programlar sundum
şarkılar söyledim Gençlik programı Bilim
Teknoloji programı dünden bugüne Jazz
programı en son TRT Okul'da A Haber
canlı yayın sunarak birçok STK sivil
toplum kuruluşlarının temsilcileriyle
bir araya geldim o yüzden hemşireme hem
bilgimi geliştirdim
işte Oo sayede hem bilgi gördüm
genişletmiş olmam da hem sanata karşı
yeteneğim bu yıllar sonra sahnede bu
defa tarih anlatmaya karar ver bilgileri
sunmaya ama sadece tarih bilgisini böyle
Okullardaki Efendim yöntemle değil de
tekdüze bir yöntemle değil de sanatla
bitmiştir edebiyatta birleştirerek
yapmaya karar verdim Buna Çünkü ben çok
iyi biliyorum ki sen müzik insanın
hayatında en büyük etki bırakan
yöntemdir yoldur olgudur burada çok iyi
kullanmak gerekir Bunu nereden öğrendim
aslına bakarsanız hikaye dönüyor
dolaşıyor bizim cumhuriyet tarihi ulu
önder Atatürk
o sahnelerde tarih anlatmaya karar
verdikten sonra bilgi paylaşmaya karar
verdikten sonra okumalarım çok ama çok
arttırdım beni asla buraya getiren şey
sanıyorum bu kararımda bundan 7-8 sene
önce babam rahmetli babamdan kalma bir
kitap geçti elime kitap kitabın adı
Amerikan tarihinde Türk Kurtuluş Savaşı
ile Acaba bizim Kurtuluş Savaşı'mızı
Amerikan tarihi Amerikan gazeteleri
nasıl anlatıyordu Her şey bu hikaye bu
kitapla başladı aslına bakarsanız o
kadar farklı anlatılıyordu ki tarih
bizim bildiğiniz bizim okullarda
öğrendiğimiz şekilde değil de
başkalarının gözleriyle başkalarının
bakış açısıyla da anlatılıyordu işte o
zaman karar verdim bilmediğimiz çok şey
var öğrendiğimiz çok şey gereken çok şey
var başka bakış açısına ihtiyacımız var
böyle çok iyi öğrendim Cumhuriyet
tarihimize alakalı hem Bunlar Hem bizim
Nerede hata yaptığınızı anlat bu
Dairelerde evde Neyi nasıl başardığımızı
anlatan hikayeler hikayeler arasında bir
de
bir Özsoy Operası hikayesini bastım
bilmiyorum Bir deniz var mıdır Özsoy
Operası bizim Cumhuriyet tarihinin ilk
operasyonda gerçek ilk Türk Operası dırr
Acaba nasıl ortaya çıkmış bir Opera
neden ortaya çıkmış nasıl yapmışlar diye
araştırınca ta 1934 senesine kadar
gittim inanılmaz da bir gaylerde
kahramanlarla karşılar
1934s nesneyi gelmiştim o sene İran
şahıs bekledim Türkiye'yi ziyarete
gelmeye karar verir değişimleri yerinde
görmek istiyor Atatürk'e de bir araya
gelmek istiyor da bip
böyle bir iki günlük ziyaret değil
birkaç ay sürecek yol ayısıyla derhal
bir fotokopisi toplanıyor Atatürk'ün
emrini nasıl karşılansın caneller
yapılsın ne oluyor herkes çıktı
paylaşıyor Kim diyor ki e paşam neden
fabrikalarımız gezdiriyoruz tabi diyor
Çok iyi fikir Cevatpaşa peki
okullarımızı Kız okullarımızı gezdirelim
yeni ufuklar açtı kefen kıyılarımız
devamı gezmedim hepsine Tamam diyor olur
diyor başa fakat bir türlü Tamamdır
başlayalım demiyor bir Ali Efendim eve
koymuyor noktayı bunun üzerine kendisi
soruyorlar sizin Aklınızda bir fikir
nedir başına diyor ki
beğendiler bir Opera besleyeceğiz Şimdi
şöyle bir hayal edin
1934 ünğan karasından bahsediyorum bugün
Ankara'sı gibi bir yani öyle imkanlar
dar Efendi sana neredeyse yok zaten çoğu
yurtdışında eğitime gönderilmiş
nasıl olacak Ankara dışında İstanbul'dan
sanatçı
doğru dürüst yatacak kalkacak bu otel
yok yedirecek içecek Restoran yok
ağırlanacak yerler yok ne yapacağız
efendim de diyor ki gündür Hayri
edebilir o zaman küçük Ocağı Müdürüm
edebiyatçı yazar Sen librettosu
yazacaksınız bu eserin bir retrosunu
yani operanın sözlerinizden yapacağız
hikayesini sözlerini ve kim beslenecek
diye sorulduğunda düşünüyor taşınıyor
daha iki yıl önce Paris'te eğitimi Tamam
yüklenmiş olan Ahmet Adnan Saygun
veriyor
Münir Hayri hemen diyor ki Ahmet aklına
başının emridir sen yapacaksın ilk Türk
operasının bestesini
tabi diyor Ahmet Adnan Onur diyelim
Gencecik bir besteci çok heyecanlıyım
Gerçekten ne kadar zamanımız var acaba
Bu eseri ortaya koymak için işte diyor
müdür Hayri Bey burada bir sıkıntımız
var bir sıkıntımız var bir 27 gün mı
vaktimiz var deyince Ahmet Adnan dehşete
kapılıyor ne demek 27 günümüz var mümkün
değil böyle birşey bir operasinin iki
yılda yazılır sizin haberiniz var mı
diye soruyor Hatta yani çok uğraştınız
gece gündüz çalıştıracak bir yılda
çıkarırsınız diye böyle Gelirken de
oluşurken Bir Hayli Bey Bence daha fazla
oyalanmayın 26 gün kalmak üzere diye
korkutuyor oldu
çalışmalar başlıyor Ahmet Hakan başlıyor
gece gündüz çalışıyor Peki sanatçılar
kim olacak Hani yok diye Ankara'yı
Ankara'da o zamanlar musikî muhallebi
beklediği yeni açılmış Efendim müdürü de
Zeki görme İstiklal Marşı müdüre
gidiyorlar ikisi birlikte diyorlar ki
hani bizim öğrencilerimize ihtiyacımız
var onları yetiştirmemiz gerekiyor hep
polis olacaklar hemen olacaklar geceli
Gündüzlü çalışmamız gerek geçirebilmeniz
için diyor ama Zeki Bey bundan pek
hoşlanmıyorlar daha öğrenci dersleri var
sınavları var Yok efendim lipaya değil
fakat ısrar lardan sonra bile Paşa'nın
emri Ya zaten peki peki Tamamdır ancak
ancak günde yarım saat alabilirsiniz
öğrencilerimi diye hakikaten işi zora
sokuyor Yapacak bir şey yok biliyorsunuz
Atatürk en çok sanatçıya e herkesi Ama
en çok da sanatçılara Efendi saygı duyar
da Dolayısıyla Emir Demir zack'in göre
öyle diyorsan öyledir deniyor sadece
günde yarım saatte çalışmalar başlıyor
zamana kadar hızlı geliyor Biz geçiyor
ki 27 26 gün müsaade böyle hızlı akıyor
ki Ne yapıyor peki Akşamları gidiyor
evine partisyonları böyle güzel bir
eliyle Yarım saat içinde yazarak 5 Kemal
o zaman öyle oluyor
bu sefer yarım saat Yarım saat çalışıyor
zamanda bir anda hızlı hızla geçerken
okuyup bakıyor diye gidiyor çalışmalar
artık gecelere sabahlara kadar sarmıyor
her şey tabip ve Atatürk de bütün bu
çalışmaları gururla ve heyecanla izliyor
Bebeği yeni bir bebeği daha dünyaya
Cumhuriyet onun en değerli eseri bebeği
Cumhuriyeti'nde yavruları dünyaya geldi
başlıyor filmlerde çok zordu yolunda
peki burada hemen baktım var mı takip
ediyorum yani neden Opera istemiş
olabilir nereden gelmiş olacak ben onu
hızlıca lütfen arıyorsun size hikaye
Efendim 1913 senesinde Bulgaristan Sofya
askeri ataşe Ken haber almış şehirde bir
büyük bir Festival Opera
eserleri temsilcileri veriliyor eve bir
oyun bir eser var ki Aman aman çok ses
getirmiş Herkes onu görmek istiyor
atatürki Mustafa Kemal Biz de görülmüş
oldu Yok yok ya da büyükelçi o zamanlar
birlikte onu görmeye gidiyorlar bu eser
temsil adıda Carmen kaybeden izlemeye
gidiyor
tıklım tıklım birazcık Kuyruk var bağır
çağır ilk perdeyi izliyorlar nasıl bir
Görkem nasıl bir İhtişam Şehit güzellik
resmi kasılıyor üçüncüye dalıyor Mustafa
Kemal an taksi arada abi bakıyor şarkı
çalışıp Erdal eşiyle birlikte localar
davet ediyorlar beğendiniz mi diye
soruyorlar hareketleri Hoca da Mustafa
Kemal'e de Büyükelçisi Ali Fethi Okyar a
Mustafa Kemal Paşa
majesteleri seni çok beğendim çok
beğendim diyor Ha biraz böyle düşünceli
sonra yerinde yerlerini tekrar
geçiyorlar ikinci perdede izleniyor
bitiyor her şey büyük Efendim ilgi alaka
bağırış çağırış derken
bu otellerini görüyorlar fakat uyku Peki
bir sürü gözüne girmiyor Mustafa
Kemal'in sabaha karşı 3 gibi Şakir
zümrenin yani Bulgaristan Eğitim
Komisyonu üyesi Şakir zümrenin kapısını
çalıyor bu Mustafa Kemal şak yüzünü full
yatağından Allah Allah hayırdır inşallah
Sabah saatinde Azim Buyrun içeri diyor
alıyor düşünceli hala Mustafa Kemal
oturduğu yerden yazıyor Şakir Ben şimdi
anladım Balkan savaşlarındaki yenilginin
sebebini Allah Allah Bir Cümleyi şöyle
dikkat kesiliyor şarkısını istiyoruz
WhatsApp'a bu saatinde gelmiş böyle ben
şimdi anladım Balkan savaşlarına
ilginizi sebebi ne baksana diyor
Bulgarlar için ben bu adamları daha da
Çoban zannederdim lar operalarının ipe
binalarını inşa etmişler sanatçıların
yetiştirmişler müzisyenlerini ve
kollarını yapmaya öğrenmişler
kostümlerin herşeylerini bunu iyi
yapmışlar ne zaman ne zaman bu medeniyet
düzeyi yetişmişler Şakir acaba Biz de
bugün bu medeniyet düzeyine
erişebileceksiniz diye soruyor yokuz 100
13934 de aklına koyduğu medeniyet
düzeyine ilişkin planlarını başlatıyor
ilk cümleyi hatırlatıyorum tekrar diyor
ki ben şimdi anladım bunların bir
bunlara neden savaşlarda yenildiğimiz
Balkan savaşlarının yeni sebebini Çünkü
e Savaş kazanmayı
aynı zamanda bir sanat olarak gören zeka
işi olarak gören ve medeniyet İş olarak
görev 102 adam bahsediyoruz Ayrıca ben
atatürkü bilgisini sanatla yöneten Gider
olarak görüyorum sana zekasını ne kadar
kıymetli zeka olduğunu savaşları dahi
kazandırabilecek inizi anlatmaya çalışan
biri işte Belki o yüzdendir ki hepsi
operands olsun bu yavrularımızı olsun
istiyorum müziğin Senfoni Biz olsun
istiyor işte o
1934 Ahmet koydu şeydi Özsoy aramıza
gerçekleştiriyor Efendim baktınız çok
dar aldı Aslı hikaye müthiş hemen sonra
gidiyorum Nihayet Eser bütün
zorluklarına çok zorluklarla ama alın
teriyle başarıyla gerçekleşiyor Eser
hazır şaha Ankara'da burada
biliyorsunuz resim Heykel Müzesi o zaman
küçük Ocağı binasında Şah ağırlanıyor
Eser sahnede bütün oyuncular sanatçılar
sahnede de Kral Baba şahbaba Feridun
soruyor ikiz oğullarımız soruyor herkes
bütün köylü halk orada mı ikizoğulları
yok ortada Tur ve iğrenç nerede diye
soruyor Tur ve iğrenç hemen kısaca
onları da neden birinin adı Tarık
diğerinin iyileşme ikiz kardeşlerin İran
edebiyatında firdevsi'nin bir eseri
vardır ekle ve o evin içinde geçer bu
hikaye belki hikayede Kral şahbaba
Feridun oğullarından kilolarından Tuğra
türkistan'ın içine armağan etmiştir yine
CD İran ip armağan etmiştir ama o ikiz
kardeşler bir yaramaz rap kavga ederler
Onlar kavga edince dünya karmaşa içinde
olacak Her Cömert olur karanlık olur
savaşlar olur Ne zaman ki bu iki kardeş
ele verirler dünyada mutlu barış içinde
olur toz pembe çiçekler için her yerde
bu eserin çalışılmasını isteyen bir
hayriden isteyen hentbolu bu tema bu son
sahne Herkes orada ama bir turlu iğrenç
yok şahbaba soruyor herkes burada Batur
nerede iğrenç nerde deyince Ozan sahneye
doğru yüzünü dönüyor ve bir elini
kaldırarak kollu kaldırarak locada
oturan
Şahı işaret ediyor işte diyor ilginç
sonra Atatürk'ü işareti bu işte tur
her İranlı bir iğrenç her Türk bir
turdur diyerek sözlerini tamamlıyor Şah
çok iyi anlıyor onun ne demek istediğini
fırlıyor ayağı ve çok iyi bir Azeri
lehçesinde Kollarını açıp sarılıp
Atatürk'ü gardaşım benim
kardeşim benim
Bizim onkardeş olduğumuz onu anlatmanın
en güzel yolu bulmuş bir Opera eseri
yaptırmış hikayede bu kardeşliğin
destanını düşecekmiş Efendi
muhacirlerden çıkan yürekten çıkan Sevgi
yangınlarıyla da kuşatılmış şahıs İşte
bu olaydan çok kısa bir süre sonra da
Cenevre Anlaşması imzalanıyor ardından
sağa baktı geliyor Ben diyorum ki
dünyanın en şık en zayıf en ince
düşünülmüş Diplomasi örneği de Böylece
bütün dünyaya öğretmiş oluyorsun bu en
iyi yankılanma yolu olduğunu yöntemi
olduğunu ben zaten geldim yaşayarak
yorum ama Atatürk'ün de pek çok
başarısından ta
yüzyıldan buraya
sesinin hala çıktığını geldiğini
duyulduğunu bilirsin Bana göre en güzel
Yankı bu diye düşünüyorum ben sürem
doldu teşekkür ediyorum İnşallah başka
ortamlarda uzun uzun anlattı